all right Philip is with us in Pensacola
Florida hi Philip how are you I'm great
Dave thanks for taking my call
sure I just finished the Money Makeover
my dad got it for me for my birthday and
I finished it and was very motivated to
start cutting into my student debt I'm
27 I'm a schoolteacher and I have 33
eight and student loans right now I just
cleared out my savings so I could have a
thousand dollars so my question is when
I break down my student loans I have six
unsubsidized loans one subsidized loan
so I'm really just curious what's the
difference
which one should I pay on pay off first
you know should I treat it more like a
debt snowball let's start with the six
point eight you gotta go you gotta pay
them all so you might as well pay them
all smallest to largest okay just like
we need knowing because I have you know
my minimum payment is $450 now with my
every dollar budget tool I'm thinking I
can do about $1,200 a month good done in
about two and a half years excellent and
that's not counting whatever I can make
there in the summer excellent
so should I just do my minimum $404 four
hundred and fifty and then and then take
your smallest debt and throw the other
eight hundred or so at it that you can
do a month so what's your smallest loan
um thirty two dollars and that's at six
point eight $32 $13.32 six hundred and
one
okay well we don't know what's going to
talk about the $32 just write a check
and pay that one off the 601 you're
going to pay off out of that pay 450 and
then put 600 on that one and knock it
out right and then what's the next one
820 no good you're going to get the next
month and then that's what they'll see
then at six point two percent you don't
care about the percent I don't care
about the percent the interest rate is
not relevant just you know we've knocked
out three debts in a month and a half
here in our discussion right now
yeah 32 608 20 boom they're gone and you
just do them in that order regardless of
whether they're subsidized whether
they're private whatever they are
they've all got to be paid and so let's
just get them done as fast as we can and
the more you do that by the way that 450
is no longer 452 main Tinka just got rid
of three loans so you don't have that
payment anymore and now that you got
that payment freed up that's going to be
even more towards that next one so maybe
down to I don't know 400 or something
now that you got rid of those payments
and so that means now we've got a little
bit more to throw at the smallest debt
as you come up on it on the debt
snowball that's exactly how it's
supposed to work and it does work it
does work so hey thanks for the call hey
you guys Rachael Cruz here hope you're
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and did
you know that I have my very own YouTube
channel yes that's right kind of better
than
Dave Ramsey channel don't tell them I
said that I'm kidding I'm kidding so
subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you